it's a bit about where brew lemasters
come from there Nelson
little boola was actually born at
Budapest zoo in Hungary and at a bit of
a tragic start because his mother passed
away only one week after his birth so
that was very sad but I must say they
did an absolutely fantastic job they
took hold of the baby started caring for
it as their own and immediately
contacted us because monkey world is the
home to the European crash for orphaned
orangutans so young bulu made his way
over here and will be joining all of our
other orangutans soon how important was
him - it was it for him to get here that
quickly then and to be getting this care
for you guys well for young orangutans
they spent up to 7 years with their
mother so that's a long childhood if you
will and every moment is precious you
can see that right now already he's
looking at me oh look at you he's
starting to zero in and track and
identify people's faces and every mother
out there will know that there's that
point when their infant starts really
engaging and recognizing them and it's
really important that he's around other
orangutans when he starts doing that so
although we're still caring for him
right now he's meeting and seeing the
other orangutans daily and at this point
in his development that's quite
important so we're really pleased he got
here so quickly and the Sumatran
orangutan they're very endangered now
aren't they they're they're on the
critically endangered live yea Sumatran
orangutans there's estimates that
there's only seven thousand left in the
wild and that's probably quite a high
estimate their habitats being destroyed
poachers are taking infants from the
wild for the black market trade so he is
an incredibly rare little chap as well
as just being beautiful I mean he's just
gorgeous we're doing everything we can
for him to not only care for him
physically but to meet his needs
mentally and most importantly for us to
get him living with other orangutans
again